Tell me if you disagree with this.
Okay,
because I'm a psychologist,
not a sociologist,
and so I'm dabbling in things that are
outside of my field of expertise and
there is some danger in that,
but the,
the central postmodernists claim seems
to me that because there's a near
infinite number of ways to interpret a
complex set of phenomena which which
actually happens to be the case that you
can't make a case that any of those
modes of interpretation are canonical
and so if they're not canonical and if
that canonical element isn't based in
some kind of reality than it serves some
other master,
and so the master that it hypothetically
serves for the postmodernists is nothing
but power because that seems to be
everything that they believe it.
They don't believe in competence.
They don't believe in authority.
They don't seem to believe in an
objective world because everything is
language mediated.
So it's an extraordinarily cynical
perspective that that because there's an
infinite number of interpretations,
none of them are canonical.
You can attribute it to everything to
power and dominance.
Okay,
so that that seemed like a reasonable
summary of the radical relativism.
It's a radical relativism now,
but the strange thing is despite.
Okay,
and so what goes along with that is the
demolition of grand narratives and so
that would be associated,
for example,
with the rejection of thinkers like Don
and Eric Norman,
because of course their foundational
thinkers in relationship to the idea
that there are embodied grand narratives
that's never touched,
but then despite the fact that the grand
narrative is rejected,
there's a neo Marxism that's tightly,
tightly allied with postmodernism.
That also seems to shade into this
strange identity.
Politics and I don't.
Two things.
I don't understand the causal
relationship there.
Like the skeptical part of me thinks
that postmodernism was a,
was an intellectual.
It's intellectual camouflage for the
continuation of the kind of pathological
Marxism that produced the Soviet Union
and that it has no independent existence
as an intellectual field whatsoever.
But I still can't understand how the
postmodernists can make the no grand
narrative claim but then immerse
themselves in this grand narrative
without anyone pointing out the
evidence.
Contradictions.
Like I don't understand that.
So what do you think about?
Well,
I can only speak about literary know
professors really,
and they seem to me almost universally
in theU ,
s to being very naive or they,
they,
they seem to know nothing about actual
history,
political science or economics.
So it,
it is simply an attitude.
They have an attitude of Marxism become
simply a badge by which they telegraph
their,
um,
their solidarity with the working class
that they have nothing to do with,
right?
I mean,
and generally nothing but contempt.
Yes.
And,
and,
and the thing is that the,
the,
the campus leftists are almost notorious
for their,
uh,
for their rather snobbish treatment of
staff.
I mean,
they don't,
they don't have any rapport with the
actual working class members of the,
um,
of the infrastructure,
the janitor,
the janitor is,
and you know,
even the,
even the secretaries,
it was kind of high and mighty
aristocracy and there were just,
these are people who um,
who have wandered into the English
department and our were products of a
time when I'm doing the new criticism.
They were when history with history and
psychology had been excluded.
Me and my ambition.
Okay.
Was,
I mean I love the new criticism.
Okay.
As a,
as a style of textual analysis.
Right?
And,
and the and the new criticism had
multiple interpretations.
Okay.
That were possible and we're encouraged.
In fact,
one of the great projects was made in
Max series.
Twentieth Century views were what you
had at least some books.
I adored them in college and it was
about Jane Austin or about Emily Bronte
or about wordsworth and they were
collections of alternate views of the
same thing.
The idea that there were no alternative
views and there was no relativistic
situational kinds of interpretive
approach is nonsense.
But the point was we needed to restore
history to literary literary study.
Okay.
And we needed to add psychology to it
because it was,
it was great animus against Freud.
When I arrived in,
in graduate school,
in fact,
I actually went into the director of
graduate studies and protesting the way
Freud and Freudian were used as,
as negative terms pay in a sneering way
by that very wasp professors.
Right.
So we need to do it.
Actually,
it seemed like we were moving there,
get in there early.
Nineteen seventies was a great period of
psycho biography about great.
About political figures.
Okay.
And so I thought it's happening in all
of a sudden they all got short circuited
by this arrival of,
of poststructuralism and postmodernism
in the,
in the 19 seventies.
Right.
Um,
so I,
I,
I feel I'm an old historicist okay.
Now not a new historical.
So I mean,
I think new stores.
So it was an absolute scam,
right?
It.
And it's like,
it's just a way.
It's like tweezers you'd like just,
you pick a little bit of this,
a little bit of that,
a little bit of that you make a little
tiny salad and someone that is atomized
thing,
right?
It's supposed to mean something.
It's all can be very superficial,
very cynical,
very distance.
I like,
I,
I am,
uh,
I am the product.
Okay.
Of Old historicism German philology.
I decide my,
my first choice of profession when I was
a child.
What was Egyptology archeology,
[inaudible] I'm.
Everything I ever think about or say is,
is related to an enormous time scheme.
Okay.
From from antiquity and indeed from the
Stone Age,
and that is the problem with these
people.
They're their male educated.
The postmodernist and academic Marxists
are male educated,
embarrassingly so.
Okay.
They know nothing before the present,
so call okay is absolutely a joke before
the enlightenment.
Okay.
You mean per perhaps he might be useful
to people to talk about what happened at
after Neil classicism,
which by the way,
he failed to notice a lot of what he was
talking about.
Okay.
Turns out to CB simply the hangover of
neoclassicism.
Okay.
This is how ignorant that man was.
I mean,
his head was.
He was not talented as a researcher.
He knew absolutely nothing.
Okay.
What stuff?
You know,
nothing about antiquity.
How can you make any kind of large
structure,
large mechanism to analyze western
culture without knowing about classical
antiquity?
Okay.
He did not see anything from some person
who had no business making large
theoretical statements about anything.
Well,
maybe,
maybe part of it is that if you,
if you generate an intelligible doctrine
of radical relativism,
then there is no reason to assume that
there are distinctions between
categories of knowledge or between
different levels of quality of
knowledge.
Right.
So I've seen the same thing in the
psychology departments,
although we have the,
uh,
what would you call it?
The luxury of being bounded at least to
some degree by the empirical method and
by biology,
right?
It's one of the things that keeps most
of the branches of psychology relatively
sane,
you know,
because the real world is actually built
into it to some degree.
But if you accept the postmodernist
claim of radical relativism,
then you completely demolished the idea
that there are quality levels that are
associated with education because
everything becomes the same.
And that seems to me to be a perfectly
reasonable justification for maintaining
ignorance.
You know,
like Food Co.
I actually found him the most readable
of the lecan.
There are de fuko trIad.
You can read fuko.
I read madison civilization and a couple
of his other books and I thought they
were painfully obvious.
You know the idea that mental disorder
is in part a social construct is self
evident to anybody who has even a
smattering of psychiatric training.
I mean the real narrow medical types
tend to to think of a mental disorder,
let's say as something that might be
purely biological.
They have a peer disease model,
but nobody's who's a sophisticated
thinker ever thinks that it's a bit
partly because medicine is a brand of
engineering,
not a brand of science because it's
associated with health and the
diagnostic categories are hybrids
between physiological observation and
sociocultural condition.
Everyone knows that and so when I read
madness and civilization,
I thought,
well that's not radical.
That's just bloody self evident.
I actually think that he began know the
entire turn toward a total theological
grounding of,
of modern psychology,
social psychology,
and was was well,
well launcher the 19 twenties for
example,
know the levels of ignorance of these.
These people moving with all original
have not read durkheim.
They've not read mocks of or are they
not read erving goffman.
Okay,
so in other words,
to me for everything is the costing of
the estimate because I had read the
sources from which he was borrowing
without attribution,
but I mean,
again,
I know these people,
I mean I,
I've met him in some cases,
knew them in graduate school,
people who went onto become these,
these,
these admirers of fico,
lack on dairy dot and I know what their
training was there.
Training was pureLy within the english
department.
That's all they ever knew.
They never made it any research outside
of that.
Right.
And so the idea for coal is simply this
is a mechanism,
it's like a little tiny kit by which
they can approach everything in culture
and then with the contortions of
language that deliberate labyrinthine,
elitist language at the same time as
pretending to be a leftist.
Okay.
This is one of the biggest frauds.
every practice.